what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation listen up guys we're gonna
watch the Chucky this isn't toe finale
today John's gonna catch all the Easter
eggs Chucky expert expert ladies and
gentlemen uh if you guys didn't know we
did a interview with the Chucky Creator
the man himself Don
Mancini yeah it was a great one he was
supposed to be talking for like 15
minutes went a little bit longer than
that because it was going so well and
yeah I think it was a really really
great interview I actually yeah you guys
would really enjoy it so please give it
a watch Link in the description box and
pin comment but uh leave a like that's
all we asked right now please go ahead
leave a like and thank you to all for
showing your support over to us at
patreon full interaction watch along
with your own copy for Chucky available
over there and we cover a bunch of shows
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch alongs included and uh I don't
know why I'm talking so nice so I'm like
I'm talking so soft like that's good
it's it's just a good comforter for
people before we get involved Carnage
yes you know yes your subtle Dosa tones
all right yes I speak Spanish all right
let's do it
do you think his whole life is flashing
before his eyes
all the lives of all the Chuckies
oh God Easter eggs Galore yeah
did you always plan on killing your
mother the therapist or was it a
spontaneous decision hey I got the kid
back
so doc here's the deal it's way too hot
of a therapist man these are teenagers
yes
oh my God this is like a plan from way
back when all you have to do is
right man get those core wounds going
foreign
therapist Scientology was right
dang
it makes more sense why it took them so
long to get away
neat
yep
first order of business
eleven nine eighty eight
first actual doll I think it might be it
sure looks like because like the facial
structure's a little different skin tone
yeah
damn she must have been a gifted
therapist who have a practice at that
age
yes holiday episode
[Laughter]
hi my name is chopping days just got out
of rehab what a time Jump one of the
very few things I never posted about on
Tick Tock or Instagram because
it didn't fit into the perfect
commercial for the perfect life I was
trying to advertise but the engagement
would have been through the roof Lexi
it's been a monster in my life
wow it's a miracle I'm not a hooker
hey there's still time you know it's
also Chucky's probably a reason you're
not why don't you talk about that in in
group therapy
stay here it's the holidays
could be with people who love you oh
monster
Mrs cross
called the mother of my
what kind of neighbor would I be if I
wasn't here to take in a poor orphan
during the holidays not a very good one
two
two
what
wait Devin oh my God
Chucky Christmas special the school has
been permanently closed and the
Archdiocese of Camden had no comment
oh
can't shut the Lord down
you can
they've tried
the same actor makes me wonder how they
do certain shots
you get that hand touch the doctors say
that they have
days no maybe less
I can't lose Glenn
the doll
I know that you know what we have to do
yes oh no why do you think I saved it
all these years
to get you in here
oh and you're the only one who knows how
to do this
[Laughter]
whoa
what the hell I deserve it the Chucky
card never leave the cave without it
never leave a trail of dead bodies
without him I wonder what Chucky's
credit score is take a look
oh no oh Christ
there's almost a Ryan Murphy quality to
this episode American Chucky story
Merry Christmas doctor Merry Christmas
scalpel uh here okay ready
oh no holy [ __ ] you yes it's me Dr
Robert rasulus
oh are these flowers
oh dude you had that coming come on
copper everything okay
put Glenn so in the cops body
what are you gonna do
clear yay
yes oh cool
hey everything okay in there
I heard someone's head Catch Fire you're
gonna
set off the sprinklers guys Merry
Christmas Mom
Glenda
classic fireplace shot
crispy
[Music]
oh they both had to go back in huh damn
that was okay they all can't live
without both of them
can't find it
a
suitable
I think mommy just found your next
sublet wow am I done yet can I see it's
the original voice act Bring Back Billy
Boyd
[Music]
oh
it's me
I love me you updated look what should I
call you now
Glendora
Gigi call me Gigi that's great till we
go online and shop for a little tiny
mommy you wrinkle my trash
I thought I might do some traveling
where do you think you might want to go
England
I want to explore my roots
um kind of clocking that actually
yeah I was gonna say if I were you I
would dial it back to about a seven
what would Jennifer Tilly do
[Music]
Crank that [ __ ]
let's do it
[Music]
give you a lift to the post office post
office
I love that they have their little day
them licensing yeah
Wild
let's go to The Chopping mall I couldn't
wait till tomorrow so
did some research online podcasting
setup
oh my God it is it's like old times
oh I haven't really been into podcasting
for a year
I'm kind of done with it
okay
I'm sorry [ __ ] ah you idiots you rude
Christmas Jake it is cool though
thanks
so you probably spent all his money on
that they don't know each other anymore
Stone
oh that's that's actually really sad
yeah so excited to give it a present
just how far apart those chairs are like
oh it feels like we're gonna have a
really bloody Christmas ending
sufferable
[Music]
I hope I like it no it's okay if you
don't though
you know I just exchange it for
something you think is better Jake oh
Jake we were finally back together
all he did was ignore how he felt about
stuff
about GC
all this time you said you've been
together
that's what you podcast about yeah
everyone loves drama this is wildly
inappropriate um they're just being
honest the dinner table is no place for
that
parts to live by I'm sorry
it's gone wrong in my life this is your
apology look Michelle Mrs cross oh
I know you think that Lexi just cares
about herself but that's not true
oh she's been trying really hard and the
least you can do is listen to her thanks
Jake they're real friends
oh everything that I've blamed you for
I'm also a guilty of doing I never
really thought about what you might be
going through
I think we're both more alike than
either of us wants to admit
I'll be running for mayor I'm glad
you're learning how much your behavior
affects other people
I've made some mistakes too remember
it's a Christmas miracle
it's a start how about YouTube just make
up already
[Music]
children speak the truth
come once Chuck you're gonna make his
big entrance when's he gonna pop out of
the turkey
I really like how they really hone in on
being a Christmas horror episode and
pull this out every year all right
I thought I wasn't good enough for you
insane yeah great hair yeah well Chucky
may be gone but still stuck with the
same old me it's exactly the you I want
the Jake who makes weird [ __ ] art
the Jake was long
curly hair the hair that's what I'm
talking about the hair get it you guys
this is very sweet the YouTube please
stop making out on my floor so I can get
some sleep
we'll move it to the couch and the best
Christmas present I've ever got
speaking of which you deceived the
receipt for that [ __ ] right shut up
uh
Christmas mistletoe
nothing could ruin this Christmas
now let's have a slow steamy sexy yeah
close-ups deep behaving this is great
and all but can you too please stop
doing it so I can get some sleep
[Music]
oh Dad
I actually have some weird ounce of
respect for this show if they just
edited yeah
and it was a lovely Christmas the end
[Laughter]
no let's go Chucky Christmas
one second later
that's great I love how tidy that
chainsaw is
all snug in their beds
dance in there they're [ __ ] skulls
I'll take it from here Caroline Oh I
enjoyed my milk and cookies wearing a
silly Red Cap I flew with a flash it's
[Music]
just left this must have been a very fun
episode to write
oh no I hope Chucky doesn't kill her I
know how many Jennifer Tilly deaths can
we handle in one season
she was able to get inside so easily
take off her shoes so she didn't make
noise
remember we met last year
I need to post this
oh my gosh it's so excited oh no I was
wondering if this would be it oh no
they're not actually they're gonna kill
her off now huh
whoa
oh
[Music]
wow
[Laughter]
oh my gosh
that's it
how can you not hear this it's the
quietest chainsaw
[Laughter]
God it's like art the Clown
that was
quite where have you been all my life
so tight you're supposed to be dead you
know if I had
time I heard that
give your heart
where are those four kids gonna do now
they're gonna Rest In Pieces
oh yeah
for that Barrel line
ah future season you're not gonna get to
this
[Music]
challenge accepted
[Music]
see damn
roast those chestnuts
[Music]
die for good oh dear
so sad
let's see
let me go
all the all the drugs you'll
you'll ever hold me truck I need it
it's so much bisecting
where's chicken Tiffin
oh
Jake
oh my God
wow
God it almost looks like a center bite
now full Evil Dead yeah yeah
the Evil Dead full Hellraiser
damn go Lexi where's her sister
he can't she's gonna bleed out she's
like he's such a good guy no Tevin you
are the lucky one
what
oh no
hold this
what
what's happening
is there is there a phone down
she have a piece of Charlie Ray in there
and the knives now what is happening
right now
Monday my real mommy would come for me
he told me a long time ago
but the lady downstairs
really adopted me oh that's why I never
fit in here oh wow you lied you're not
my real sister
you told me to just pretend to be afraid
of him
and I fooled you
I'm from everyone she really did have
potential what have you done with him
oh I killed him
for real this time
we'll be sorry Lexi
mommy yes honey let's go all right sweet
face
sweet face
yeah it's twisted I forgot about that
Exchange in season one of that
I would not let that Chucky doll out of
your sucked back that chainsaw
had you seen the suspect before
absolutely
it was Jennifer Tilly
I was overrated
we need to find my sister now I'm sorry
but we're trying everything we can do oh
my God
the teacher cool teacher hey welcome
back do you remember Trucking
I knew it
let's go
[Laughter]
Chucky Takes Manhattan
I don't know we just skipped over the
Chucky New Year what gives
there is such a ride Murphy quality in
this episode
look
I owe you an apology
I'm sorry about what happened with Glenn
I am God like an action show yeah Tanika
identity you heard from GT
they call me once a week oh oh
tell them I said hello okay
I'm still quite
and I love what you what you've done to
your hair
yes
Wicked those are some amazing binoculars
give me the power I beg of you
it's like bride
oh God damn it
oh
that's actually kind of scary
[Laughter]
dang
oh oh goodness
she knew the whole time
my true love gave to me wow wild 30
seconds
on the 22nd days
[Music]
dude good vocab in here
[Music]
yeah
friends don't let friends drive drunk
responsible Chuck
's oh boy
okay that was a wild episode guys that
was a delight it was wild wild stallion
stuff that was a cup of cheer
um yeah I thought they did a such an
excellent job with a full-long Christmas
horror episode you don't really see much
Christmas horror and when you do it
doesn't really look appealing in the
marketing
do I really want to do this at Christmas
it's gonna make me feel ugly for
Christmas like this just looks lucky and
it doesn't feel like there's a real
Spirit about it but what I liked about
the first half of this episode
especially
was I mean I think the reveal of the
therapist and how that went down like oh
yeah that lines up really well with the
time of how it played on the last
episode because I think I had that
thought of like what took them so long
yeah
it lands up really well and like what
was the Transformations they acknowledge
the ants that are really fast but what I
thought was really well executed about
it was the build of
the first half really feels like a
Christmas episode with an occasional
reminder of some of the horror stuff you
know like the trans the The Rebirth of
or or depending on how you want to
interpret it it's the true coming to
form identity of Gigi you know like that
sequence of the hospital like yeah a
little violent whatever
um but you know it's mainly the
Christmas mood of a of a family
dysfunctional one and this and Jake and
Devin but they are a real they're still
family and overcoming some of the
tribulations there and the awkward
family dinners but coming together in
the end out of love
and the the tone of it felt like a good
Christmas movie which is that
percolating horror you know yeah just
just that knowledge that something is
going to drop at some point yeah but
still felt Christmas yeah and then the
last half I just went Bonkers and uh had
that pacing of like I I say it feels
Ryan Murphy and I'm talking about the
good Ryan Murphy like I'm a big American
Horror Story fan I'm I'm watching the
latest season right now I've seen every
season so I I like I like uh Ryan
Murphy's work for the most part
um at least in that realm so yeah like I
met that in a complimentary way and I I
thought this the way that this [ __ ] went
down I think we thought I remember it
might have been the episode one of the
the first episode of the Season we were
like the mom's gonna die this yeah one
of us I think said it and that we
thought this would be the season the mom
dies yeah and uh it came true I was
still surprised when it went down sure I
was like wow they're doing this after
they just had a rip hair yeah real heart
to heart and and because of the fact too
that they're actually mother and
daughter in real life it almost
reinforces that idea of like are they
really they are yeah really yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's that's part of it
so like me I was sitting here thinking
well after this moment of repair it
would be you know the time to break our
hearts and kill her but at the same time
I'm like but but there's so much more we
can do with these characters you know
and and play off their real relationship
and all that stuff I think it's safe to
assume that the actress who plays Lexi
became really demanding and wanted more
Independence away from her mom that's
requested that she be killed off or else
you wouldn't
it just seems really obvious as someone
who's never seen an interview with her
sure or read any behind the scenes and
for the first time learning that their
mother and daughter
I'm pretty confident in what I've just
assessed it's a situation yeah it's like
Mom stuck all the guys get my mom off
the set you can pay Jake and Devin
triples as long as you fire my mom I
come on guys it's pretty obvious that's
what really went down yeah
um oh yeah we so you see that the
therapist has been they tied it full
circle that this was Chucky's plan from
the get-go and that she helped make them
the targets for him yeah that's
interesting they brought it back and it
did feel like they brought it back to
the first season what's setting up a
really strange season three yeah
what is season like season three looks
just like some type of Thriller yeah
yeah Nika and Tiffany are gonna be here
or if you know they're not gonna kill
Tiffany I don't think but yeah Nico and
Tiffany are gonna be in some kind of
like John Wick action thriller of just
like always looking over your shoulders
on the road Thriller yeah yeah yeah and
then Jake and Lexi and Devin are just
going to be like in some kind of
paranoid orphan story Caroline's a
little girl Caroline yeah uh I think
that was handled exquisitely yes because
you kind of forget about some of that
stuff like she's in the first episode of
this season and she gets the doll
yet uh we really don't really go out of
the way to remind you of some of the
things that happened in the first season
but you're like but it did yeah yeah and
she did weirdly seem receptive to the
doll despite the traumatic [ __ ] that
happened and then there was a talking
about this episode that's right that's
right yeah I forgot about all those
conversations
um see that's so rewarding because yeah
it's like those manipulations pay off
and they made a really good thread out
of that in the first season of like oh
the battle for Caroline's soul and I
love that yeah they they I I wonder if
that was always the plan but the way it
comes across here it feels like it was
always the plan yeah and yeah especially
you know looking at the way they make
these seasons and and just these movies
in general you know I feel like they're
pretty good at
going to the point where you're like man
how are we going to pick up from this
you know like it seems like they're good
at doing uh things that you have some
kind of lasting impact even though you
know like Chucky will will never die uh
you know like things like killing off
Jennifer Tilly in the doll form and at
least just kind of bringing all this
Jeopardy to the dolls the human
counterparts all that stuff like it's
really well handled and it really feels
like a big culmination it feels like a
crescendo you know it'll probably
continue and yet it feels like there is
a certain level of like cost and
finality yeah this is the first the
first season ended with someone was
watching them but it felt like a real
conclusion of things and I I guess that
because like the last episode felt
this was like an extended epilogue in a
lot of ways yeah like more of a
conclusion for some of the threads of
Gigi and and that like that storyline
was like yeah we definitely really
needed that and this was a major I know
of course with Lexi getting clean and
stuff and uh yeah I I did I did like it
I did like it quite a bit and it's
interesting that they they ended it so
strongly on we're going for season three
hardcore and you know it's like okay
it's gonna be a a a search for Caroline
I want them to do a time Jump 10 years
later get new actors yeah
can play Caroline yeah
somehow look younger and she'll play
aged up Caroline really piss off the
audience parents like who are these
people I don't want to watch them uh
yeah well and two I mean that young
actress does a good job because I feel
like you know it this this especially is
is you know you got to play innocent kid
but also you got to play evil adult or
at least kid you know accessible to evil
adults and that scene at the dinner
table when she was just listening and
they kept cutting back to her I remember
having the thought of this little girl
is actually quite great at displaying
emotion there because the things she
talked about in that monologue at the
end uh when she's
being held hostage that you know she's
been she's an outsider and stuff I'm
like that's what I was feeling from her
in that moment like oh what it must be
like to be a little girl watching these
grown-ups around you and feeling
completely isolator you're witnessing
just like adult tensions or not even
adult but like just older people
tensions and being exposed to that and
just how um isolating and sad it must
feel and I could see all that in her
performance yeah so I was like yeah this
girl's kind of even without talking
she's doing like an amazing job there so
yeah in the context I mean in the
context you you can see how the
manipulation really works uh because
because then you start to go like well
you know she's got like brown hair when
the rest of her family's blonde like you
know like even though there are physical
cues you could look at there are
certainly like you know cues and just
how everyone acts but um yeah I don't
understand everything across this felt
like the right proportion it felt like
this was really fun to make but also I
like that yeah in the first part of the
episode you do get not like you know
chintzy Christmas themes but yeah you
know you you have that sort of almost
dramatic Christmas quality where yeah
it's about
clearing some of the past angst of the
year and as much as like I like the
thing with the gift the podcasting gift
and the fact that they do get to
confront you you get a couple moments of
just intimate time to confront yeah the
character angst of the season and I
thought them making up and even just
like the three of them in the bedroom
together having this like slumber party
of sorts like even though this season
has had so much going on and we haven't
spent as much time with the three of
them together this felt it it kind of
strengthened everything else before that
in these moments because it has felt
like oh man we have not had time just to
sit and bond and to kind of uh check
back in with what our friendship is now
and I love that they acknowledge like
man Andy and Kyle's lives are just
completely absorbed by this you know is
that what we have to look forward to
and uh and yeah I thought they like you
said they did nicely to take
the Chris certain other Christmas things
with us with just an authentic approach
to where like yeah I I would have fun
putting this on during Christmas time
it'd be a bit of a non-sequitur given
the you know narrative thread of the
overall season but like this had
everything I I feel like I would want
from a Christmas horror thing like
there's some good drama some moments
that actually got me like misty-eyed
like I thought they're seen at the table
especially uh and the subsequent scene
with Devin and Jake making up those were
like really nice scenes to just let them
act and emote together and then you get
the freaking crazy ass like you know
Silent Night deadly night or or Santa's
sleigh or any number of other you know
Santa horror movie tributes with yeah
just him chains like the amount of
bisecting and crazy chainsaw gags was
just like you gotta appreciate the
animation and the and the you know
physical effects and everything that
goes into that stuff too because it's I
mean they they really don't skimp and I
like that
you know throughout the season they
really know and funny because like as
like the movies are more spread out so I
feel like you have the benefit of time
to give you that sort of like well you
know uh uh
I don't know like there's something
about the show where you assume that you
know like things will kind of continue
from here pretty pretty uh fluidly and
uh and yet you know it still feels like
I don't know there's a I had a train of
thought now it's good and it's and it's
since sort of uh since sort of vanished
um I'm not gonna help you I appreciate
that I should just suffer out here in
the desert I appreciate it dehydrate
that's good
foreign
I want you to
oh that's what it is yeah it's like you
sure you got it I do sure you're not
gonna lose right now because part of the
charm is that you have to be
conscientious about how you use Chucky
and they cut they talk in interviews and
such about not overusing Chucky not
showing Chucky too much and I feel like
given the time that passes between a lot
of the movies you know if you're not
just watching them all the time you have
that break that then when you're
building him back up and and stuff in a
movie plot you know you you have the
benefit of that time whereas here on the
show I admire that this episode and and
even the previous episode you know you
the way that they you know they don't
bombard you with Chucky I feel like that
would be harder to do in a in a show
environment over eight episodes where
it's like we know it's going to continue
and it's going to continue on a yearly
basis instead of every few years but I
feel like they still managed here to do
a really nice job of gradually fading in
the craziness of Chucky and in this
episode like the previous episode with
the exorcism and the explosion of Father
Bryce like that felt like a really big
kind of culmination of the Goran of the
gags and stuff like that and this
feeling like an epilogue you know I I
like that they sort of went that much
more sort of Hog Wild in giving us like
the big star on top of the gore
Christmas tree with you know just an
extravaganza of you know horrific uh
again chainsaw gags and things like that
um so yeah it's like the way that
they're able to temper that and not just
sort of like
feel the need to blast us with Gore all
the time so that you still maintain
those Dynamics I think is impressive
because it's Gotta yeah just be more and
more challenging
to you know be sparing with Chucky in
the right moments
the further and further we go
I'd say yeah I think uh
I'm lost
and I'm not gonna help you find yourself
I I I think what they did here was not
only make an epilogue they made like a
Christmas special yeah which was great
to to have for this character there's
something kind of cool with him in the
what is called again
Santa hat
I that can't be right nah
ferment Christmas cap
[Laughter]
um
yeah the the way they the way they had
uh Chucky and the in the Christmas hat
Christmas cat
and even when he was like bloodied up
I'm like something looks really cool
about this I don't even know exactly why
but this looks really cool
it's just that right amount of irony and
Lexi coming into her own with the like
she just hopped straight to Revenge no
time to grieve yeah that's what they
should call the season of Chucky three
No Time
title actually
yeah man that's not a bad title for a
mod movie I think that's the follow-up
to no time to die where everyone at MI6
is just trying I had no time to grieve
look over at his empty desk they're like
oh man Bond but the world's in danger we
can't grieve right now
yeah that's cool title no time to grieve
no time to save that yeah yeah save that
leave that for a rainy day you know the
Chucky and bond fans often intersect
with each other Chucky should go
anywhere and everywhere it's possible
for him to go
uh
even the colors like like yeah him with
the Santa hat because it's good it's
like it's just the right amount because
it evokes like I mean evokes part of it
reminded me of Christmas Vacation almost
because he's got the chainsaw in that
one in the Jason mask but but here it's
like they also just the colors like him
in his classic Chucky get up but the
Santa had like just the right amount
because I I could almost imagine a
version where he's in like a full-on
Santa suit uh you know to to pay like
direct tribute to any of the Myriad of
you know schlocky Christmas horror Santa
evil films well I like the dark
Christmas Vibe I love the
I love like the the feeling the cold I
love the atmosphere and the the light I
like that kind of dark blue lighting
like there's a cool visual there's
something about this episode is visually
striking I have that Krampus lighting
yeah yeah definitely that very yeah it's
very wintry it's very chilly and so much
is used so much is made and and uh you
know sort of capitalized on with all
these Christmas lights which I think
gives it a really cool just it gives the
holiday flavor but also just gives it a
more colorful interesting light palette
and especially when they're in the house
or or in the neighborhood of the house
even in some of these wide shots like
you do feel like you're in like they're
they're I like the way they oscillate
the tone because yeah you have the
moment with Nika and uh and Tiffany
which feels like you're in like a Blade
Runner version of New York and yeah it
feels like some kind of action thriller
whereas when you're in the home and when
you're in Lexi's home so much of that
does sort of feel like something that's
more like there could could be a more
warm Suburban Christmas Tale happening
just around the corner like you feel
that irony of like it's quiet and
peaceful and under if we didn't know
what the circumstances were this would
feel very Serene but it feels very sort
of you know uh dread heavy because of
the irony of all that I love too a lot
in this perform is Jennifer Tilly's
performance yeah because
you really see a much more like
vulnerable side to her this time around
you know a lot of times it's kind of
it's believable but it's it can feel a
little bit like uh I don't know it it
would this one really felt since there
was something that read more sincere
about it like
this uh even when she didn't want the
kids to die you know and
like her what I thought was great about
what they did with her character here is
they really honed in on her being a mom
and her connection and the evolution
that she had with Gigi and and like
feeling the like what Gigi says bye
wants to go on their own which was kind
of crazy to get you know
I know I wanted to but Gigi wanted to go
on their own and
even when she confronts Chucky and she
and she's like so upset about killing a
mom on Christmas and she doesn't even
want the children to die like that's
that was kind of the crazy part to me
was like she didn't want Lexi and Jake
and Devin to be killed like she that was
the last thing she wanted because her
her mother her maternal instincts after
everything she's experienced are really
coming out of her so she's really kind
of changed as a character yeah and so
when she was getting like stabbed by
them I was like wait no gosh don't do it
it's actually yeah she was trying to
keep you guys from getting killed it was
bad she said about all the bad things
but right now she's not as bad as she's
been yeah she seems like she's really
has had a a character change well her
back's on the ropes you know and I liked
uh I I like oh they they mapped this out
when Lexie goes downstairs and they're
like she wants the doll get in the bed
yeah yeah damn it you hide here like I
said Jake I'm gonna hide here in the bed
and then when she comes to the doll
that's what messed up like wow they
really map this out they're like it has
that super quick on what to do I like
that like I feel like that it's a bit
cheeky for sure but I actually really
like that they were just prepared In
This Moment the three of them especially
after everything that's happened this
season to have this go down and then
just be like no we know what we got to
do we know what their plan probably is
yeah you know and and it's not played
too I mean Lexi gives that big jump but
it's not played too hamily badass or
anything like that you know and the
writing of the characters were it showed
me that they they do a really great job
with the writing of the characters
because
you know by the time they were like
laying on the bed and [ __ ] I I realized
like I haven't even thought about Chucky
this whole time yeah it's like this
episode watching this I was like I'm
really happy they made this episode I'm
really happy that this was the end of
the season especially the season that
centers around like a Catholic School to
then end just on sort of a a genuine
Christmas celebration is nice but it was
a Christ day that was ever before Christ
all you Jewish people out there that's
right taking our Christmas that's how
could you don't you guys own enough got
11 more months that you could put your
holidays down a couple of celebrities
have told me recently death con three
you guys own everything already right
yeah you control everything leave a
little for the rest of us Jewish
Community
Chucky and Hanukkah though let's do that
next season I'm I'm psyched for that but
but this this A happy singing very very
Jewish he's a Jewish guy Don Mancini I
grew up in Catholic School yeah his real
his real name is Don mancinoowitz that's
racist that's a little bit of a racist
joke and I'm sorry to the Jewish
Community
I'm not sorry at all and I'm not sorry
that I'm not sorry uh but this this
episode had me thinking some great
racism right there
what
good racism
come come hang out with me
no this episode I gotta edit this video
John this episode made me wish strong
final Point here this episode I was
sitting here going I would watch a
full-on chunky Christmas movie given
what this is and I feel like a lot of
the strength of that I don't know if it
would work the same but yeah I was
sitting there going I would just watch
this whole episode about them and that's
Testament to the fact that yeah like
everybody knows the assignment and
there's so much love and care that goes
into the writing and the acting and
everything and the realization of all
this and uh and and it's like that
element kind of transcends the the
horror stuff to make this kind of
heartwarming even though it is like a
pretty sad episode in a lot of regards
you know and we and and you know what
I wonder here's a final point for you we
got Billy Boyd I think I didn't catch
the credit but I would imagine it's
Billy Boyd back doing the the GG voice
and I didn't even think to it was like
they're both you know I can hear both
sets of the voices in my mind but I was
like oh that's right Gigi Glenn Glenda
the doll was British what what what's
the deal with that yeah it's true where
did their their accent uh what's what's
the deal with their accent we will
probably find out when they go home and
visit their Roots but I like that even
that they're like
we're going to acknowledge this and
we're going to use it you know
yes yes respect respectable points
respect you did good there John thank
you I was be graded this whole time
that's what I
it's like you gotta pass with at least a
b or higher
all right guys what do you think about
the Truckee finale uh leave your
thoughts down below be sure to leave uh
subscribe and patreon
patron of the day show
James Smith
James you've been a patron of ours who
holy crap for 29 months
and you know what we got you this
fat ass present oh dude his big presents
say thanks for being a patron of ours
for 29 months thick ass Prez you're the
only Patron on our page
where it says Patron opted out of
receiving benefits by mail
how could you so now we had to divide
the present up
and give it to all the other patrons who
get a patron of the day shout out you're
missing out James so you're missing out
Chimes that kitten unfortunately the big
kitten is just gone like people have
received a lot of things like little
pieces in the mail and they're like they
don't even know where it belongs to and
I'm like it's obvious that's obviously a
cat's paw like put it together you [ __ ]
yeah that's obviously a cat's tail like
I've gotten so many angry messages from
other patrons I'm like look the whole
cat was supposed to go to James Smith
but we had to divide up the cat and now
you know you're a murderer Greg I'm like
I'm not a murderer
you eat meat
[Music]
[Laughter]
me me dividing up one cat in the grand
scheme of things how different is that
one versus all of the animals that
you've eaten over time how about food
for thought on that one dude that's a
vegan snack for your thoughts so James I
just want to say um I don't know where
you're from I don't know what you do
uh but all I want you to know is that
dead cat is on your hand that's on your
hands so I don't care who you are where
you're from what you did as long as you
take responsibility for that dead cat
I'll take responsibility for anything as
long as there's no consequences to
follow it sure so I think that if they
start getting some lawsuits coming my
way in some criminal charges
and then I gotta say James if you really
are that loyal of a patron
you gotta be willing to take the fall
here go get that cat go get the pieces
go get the pieces and if you can bring
the pieces together you win a prize you
do the prophecy will be complete
all righty
well happy holidays shapes love you hope
you're thankful and do while you're in
New Zealand I assume so you don't even
have a Thanksgiving I think maybe he
might be from Dragon Ball Z he's
officials from Dragon Ball Z
the amount paid from yeah I hope you're
having a Super Saiyan holiday that joke
is hilarious if you could see the
currency officials in front of you you
can see the stack of letters that
denotes it yeah and then you go it does
kind of look like DBZ but it's so it's
it's one of those jokes that requires a
bit of a visual reference in order for
it to really land it's one of those
jokes that requires someone to explain
it to you in great detail if I was like
no it's from DBZ and then cut to the
initials then you take a second to read
NZ and be like ah it's funny he's silly
did not read it properly
and then the other characters like
that's an nzd you [ __ ] New Zealand and
it makes it funny because that person is
what the audience is thinking
you wasted too much time talking I'm
sorry
[Music]